[Music]
[Applause]
here's how the survey works oh I have no
soul last that 98 we asked three
celebrities to complete a phrase our
first phrase was my least favorite thing
about my morning routine is Harrison
Ford wrote flossing my teeth it's
interesting
Lisa Kudrow wrote putting on makeup
clint eastwood wrote telling invisible
guys to get off my toilet when i'm in
bed I like to Carol Burnett wrote read a
book Seth Meyers wrote watch TV Gary
Busey wrote undo the restraints with my
teeth
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and he gets away when I saw the Space
Shuttle make its final flight to Los
Angeles last week I thought President
Obama wrote so sad that an era is over
George W Bush wrote what an amazing
technological achievement Bill Clinton
wrote check it out those planes are
doing it toddler stuff that's such a
great way of explaining things there's
nothing more relaxing than Eva Longoria
wrote green tea Jennifer Aniston wrote
scented candles Bruce Jenner wrote a
nice medieval face stretching
I hope scientists find a way to bob
costas wrote cure-all known diseases
Steve Martin wrote explore distant
galaxies Mitt Romney wrote turned hobos
into sod time always slows down when i'm
carlos beltran wrote swinging at a
perfect pitch wide reciever Demaryius
Thomas wrote catching a pass in the end
zone lindsay lohan wrote leaning forward
as the airbag blooms out from the
steering wheel I'm often mistaken for
isla Fisher wrote Amy Adams Keira
Knightley wrote Natalie Portman Johnny
Depp wrote a hip fieldmouse
I bet the writers that one wouldn't work
yeah yeah I think everyone understands
yeah what am i out what I don't know how
much money I assigned it I didn't
nothing nothing nothing
oh I'm out nothing what idiots I think
vice presidential candidate Paul Ryan
exaggerates his accomplishments because
Martha Stewart wrote he's very ambitious
John Krasinski wrote he has an inflated
self-image Paul Ryan wrote I'll answer
this question right after I beat this
grizzly bear to death with my Grammy
Award
[Music]
you think he'd use his Oscar that would
be a better weapon Grammys good enough
now I remember when up what a big deal
it was when they came out with Jesse
Eisenberg wrote the laptop computer
Sharon Osbourne wrote the color
television Larry King wrote the moon
[Applause]
yes you see real dark at night
Jagat house Meshuga Falls I really put
my foot in my mouth
after I Mitt Romney wrote spoke at that
private fundraiser Jill Biden wrote use
a curse word on the campaign trail chris
christie wrote lightly breaded it and
sauteed it
the pain doesn't stop him from
continuing to eat his foot and finally
the dumbest thing I've ever done is Greg
Allman wrote heroin Robert Downey jr.
wrote crack Kanye West wrote Kim
Kardashian
[Applause]